[Music]
hey everyone it's Stephanie here and
today I'm joined by Mike at the hardware
of Earth Mike how are you doing pretty
good so what are we looking at here
today so what we're going to demonstrate
here is we're going to talk about our
new Edge platform and it was introduced
yesterday and I'm going to show a little
contrived example here but this is to do
personal protection so the idea here is
that I put this hat on and it determines
am I ready to work and so I have a
camera sitting up here it's now
inferenced me it said oh I've detected
view you can see I have a light sitting
behind me and this is essentially saying
you know I'm ready to work so this could
be a representative of a hard hat a face
mask goggles something on both lines
okay so it's making sure things are in
compliance people are safe
Etc absolutely what's really nice about
it is the internet here has been in and
out so this will turn from red to Green
we can operate this entire thing without
the internet okay awesome this is our
cluster that sits down here this is our
three node kubernetes cluster it works
just like gke it's a fully managed
Google product uh when you have a
problem we come on hands and if you
that's it just kubernetes in the day so
we are running the model on this uh
locally without using any of the
internet that's awesome okay can I try
on the hat yes you can let's get you one
of these okay
and then what are we looking at in this
monitoring so what's really great about
this is while we have these distributed
out to the uh all the locations that
will be at we're able to Monitor and see
all of the applications up here all of
the runtime all of the health of the
system yep there you go looks like
you're ready to work
I'm ready to work yeah switching jobs
today yeah exactly okay all right
awesome well thanks Mike and enjoy the
rest of nights thank you very much
[Music]